-Performing "Tiny Dancer,"
please welcome the cast
of "Almost Famous!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ "Tiny Dancer" begins ]
♪♪
♪ -Blue-jean baby ♪
♪ L.A. lady ♪
♪ Seamstress for the band ♪
♪ -Pretty-eyed ♪
♪ Pirate smile ♪
♪ You'll marry a music man ♪
♪♪
♪ [ Together ] Ballerina ♪
♪ You must've seen her ♪
♪♪
♪ Dancing in the sand ♪
♪ And now she's in me ♪
♪ Always with me ♪
♪ Tiny dancer in my hand ♪
♪♪
♪ -Jesus freaks ♪
♪ Out in the street ♪
♪ Handing tickets out for God ♪
♪♪
♪ -Turning back ♪
♪ She just laughs ♪
♪ -The boulevard
is not that bad ♪
♪ -Piano man ♪
♪ He makes his stand ♪
[ Together ]
♪ In the auditorium ♪
♪ Looking on ♪
♪ She sings the songs ♪
♪ The words she knows ♪
♪ The tune she hums ♪
♪♪
[ Together ] ♪ Oh,
how it feels so real ♪
♪ Lying here, with no one near ♪
♪ Only you ♪
♪ And you can hear me ♪
♪ When I say softly, ♪
♪ Slowly ♪
♪ -Hold me closer, tiny dancer ♪
[ All ] ♪ Count the headlights
on the highway ♪
♪ Lay me down
in sheets of linen ♪
♪ You had a busy day today ♪
-I have to go home.
-You are home!
♪ Ahhh ♪
♪ -Hold me closer, tiny dancer ♪
♪ Count the headlights
on the highway ♪
♪ Lay me down
in sheets of linen ♪
♪ You had a busy day today ♪
♪♪
[ Together ] ♪ Ahhh, ahh ♪
♪ Ahhh, ahh ♪
♪ Ahhh, ahh, ahh ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Applause continues ]
-Wow.
Oh, my God.
Amazing.
The cast of "Almost Famous!"
Opening Thursday night
on Broadway!
For tickets, go to
AlmostFamousTheMusical.com!